he is a longtime member of the
journalism profession if you will a
best-selling author from the New York
Times back in the day and now the senior
investigative reporter for ESPN and the
host and executive producer of a new
ESPN docu-series back story Don Van
Natta back here on the show how are you
doing I'm doing great rich great to see
you let's talk about the back story um
here where it's I you got a deep dive
you choose a subject the first one was
Serena and Nyami Osaka from last year
correct let's open where did this
concept come from came from John Dahl
who was the co-creator of the 30 for 30
series right it was his idea to create a
docu-series where we would go back into
sports history and find scandal stories
controversies where there's room to run
there's some reporting we can do bring
some fresh perspectives and I was
thrilled when he called me last year and
asked if I'd be interested in hosting it
and doing the reporting and we've got
five episodes in the first season and
the first premiere episode was Serina vs
the umpire that aired the last month
Carlos Ramos from Portugal and the clash
between Serena Williams and Carlos Ramos
as she sought her 24th Grand Slam title
tying Margaret courts records yeah that
was over a year ago now and I just
remember the phone lines on this show
during an NFL season they liked for no
story
that's not NFL right except for that one
because it was just a whole big to-do as
to whose fault it was was it Serena for
going over the edge over the line why
was the umpire doing what he did in the
first place what did you learn that you
might not have known but that's exactly
what we sought out to find out who was
most at fault for a match that ended in
tears and it was the ugliest finish in
Grand Slam history by far was it mostly
Serena's fault Carlos Ramos the umpires
fault or something else
we determined rich that just about
everybody shared the fault there was
equal blame to go around
Serena certainly could have handled the
situation better she's never to this day
knowledge that she received coaching
from Patrick Mouratoglou her coach
during the match when she was called for
that set off that whole chain of events
because who gets called for that
it almost has never called for but she
insisted that she never gets coaching
and we Zapruder film like went back and
actually showed a split screen where
Murata glue makes the signal for her to
move up closer to the baseline and at
that moment she's looking right at him
and then Mirada glue nods like okay
signal received and so I asked Marat to
glue about it I went to Wimbledon and he
gives a very interesting squirrelly
answer about that almost winking as he
sort of admits right at Sarina most
likely saw the coaching signal oh that
although he doesn't quite say so what
fault does the umpire admit
well the fault of the umpire Carlos
Ramos is a by-the-book stickler for the
rules gold badge on par with the
terrific reputation but he left the
match get out of control and so we
interviewed Chrissie Evert Pam Shriver a
lot of people in tennis who said there
could have been a soft warning perhaps
at least for the coaching violation and
then the third code violation which
caused Sarina a game as a match was
spinning out of control was for verbal
abuse and there was some thought that
there
Ramos should have swallowed his whistle
let it go so you know when a chair
umpire does his job rich he's invisible
and everybody knew Carlos Ramos his name
four days after that so what's the net
what other stories are you taking a back
story view of here done so the next
episode which will debut on November 3rd
on ESPN is the banning of Shoeless Joe
Jackson we're gonna go back in history a
hundred years we just did a story a year
ago for our premiere right now we're
gonna go a century back to the Black Sox
scandal the banning of Shoeless Joe what
exactly was going on there the legacy of
shoeless joe and then draw a through
line from shoeless joe to Pete Rose who
of course was banned from baseball 30
years ago for betting on the Cincinnati
Reds and lying about it for 15 years and
then we're gonna look at legalized
gambling today in Major League Baseball
the embrace of legalized gambling by
Commissioner Manfred and the owners and
is there some hypocrisy there as you're
still holding up these villains
Shoeless Joe from a hundred years ago
and Pete Rose and we're excited about
the episode interviewed Pete Rose at the
Mandalay Bay a few weeks ago was he at a
table where he was not he signs
baseball's and book no I know yeah
yeah that's very much where it pretty
much that's right so what type of Petros
did you find I found a really surprising
when I'm really anxious for the audience
to see it I mean he almost ripped the
microphone off at one point I don't want
to give too much away he was very mad at
me early on but then you see a very
different Petros I think he saw it as a
chance for him to make his closing
argument to be in the Hall of Fame and I
think viewers are gonna be surprised by
the rose that we found okay but you got
to give me some I mean wow how did you
piss him off like well I just kept
pressing him on 1989 and the fact that
he lied for 15 years about gambling on
the Cincinnati Reds betting on baseball
I have denying it until he had that book
in 2004 and he thought I was going to
ask a question or two and I kept
pressing him almost like a prosecutor
and has he not does he not know who you
are rich you know I don't know if he
actually first of all he wasn't gonna do
the interview initially right I had to
go out there and sort of schmooze him
that'll be part of the episode see now I
always thought if Petros had done what
Mickey Mantle did and by that I mean go
on a tour of hey I had a problem and I'm
apologizing for it and I was a bad
person Father for it and I'm I'm warning
everybody don't be like me if Pete had
done that just remove alcoholism and
inserted gambling yes if he had done
that in 1990-1991
despite the fact that the individual who
banned him for life as we all know died
of a heart attack and Bart Giamatti
right I think he'd be in the in the
Baseball Hall of Fame I think you're
probably right and if he had gone on
that contrition tour and you know when
he was banned from baseball Bart
Giamatti told him you need to
reconfigure your life and reconfiguring
your life is stop gambling Pete thinks
because he stopped betting with illegal
bookmakers and only would bet in the
casinos of Las Vegas legally crying that
was a reconfiguring but you know he lied
at his most recent meeting with
Commissioner Manfred in 2015 when he
tried to get reinstated and taken off
the ineligible list again
he lied even to Manfred about whether he
was still betting legally on sports and
I believe that cost them an opportunity
then so we go into all of that and we
really show the legacies of Shoeless Joe
and Petros how they're linked and
whether they'll ever be forgiven by the
powers that be in baseball and you know
just one last on on Rozier I mean I want
to give voice to the fans who are
perhaps listening or watching us right
now Don and saying what does it matter
what PR it is and what does it matter if
he's gambling legally like everybody
else can that Major League Baseball is
now coming around on he still raked all
those hits I mean and that's why he
should be in yes in the Hall of Fame or
why can't the Hall of Fame it's a museum
tell the story of Pete Rose and put a
plaque in there with his name on it
those are the questions we're gonna
raise that's a great question
rich there's certainly a hypocrisy now
right age early baseball's putting a lot
of chips in the middle of the table
right unlegal eyes gambling hoping it'll
turbocharged the game's popularity and
so at the same time you're strolling
hope Hill holding up Pete Rose right who
is Joe is these villains we're gonna get
into all those issues in the episode
backed when is the bat when is that back
story opens November 3rd on ESPN it
premieres and it'll be on all through
November on ESPN and on all the platform
a can note of that and by the way eight
men out is one of my favorite underrated
sports move I love that sports will be
too and I interviewed John Sayles just
of New York that's right director who
plays Ring Lardner that's right you know
it in with studs tournament studs terkel
the other as the other journalists and
and sales was great and so that'll be
part of the episode so how real is a
been out is it real because it basically
it kind of exonerates Shoeless Joe
Jackson completely exonerees Shula show
makes him very sympathetic of a
character though interestingly sales
still thinks he had he was complicit
somewhat in the fix but there's all
sorts of inaccuracies in eight men out
unfortunately there were some liberties
taken the book that it's based on is
riddled with errors and again we get
into some of that heimbach story there's
a lot of myths
have it ruined it's such a good movie
it's a new sack and it's John Mahoney
yes and DB sweeney oh yeah LT place you
loose a shoeless joe yeah I do love that
Charlie Sheen it's fantastic it's right
Charlie Shen Charlie Sheen Don Van Natta
here on the Rich Eisen show what's the
NFL story do you think going on right
now 2019
it's the collective bargaining agreement
it's it's the desire of the NFL owners
rich to put this behind them so they can
do the broadcast deals and the streaming
deals and they've made some progress
from what I understand it but not nearly
enough I mean the sticking points
obviously or the revenue split which the
owners love players not so much players
not so much players would like it to get
closer to 5050
that's a stumbling-block point now the
other big one is the number of games the
owners want 18 regular season games
players only want 16 there may be some
give there we may see 17 I'm hearing 17
which is the oddest number right how do
you even figure that out I mean you
already have 17 weeks but there still
needs to be a Buy we needs to be a bye
week so then it would be an 18 game
season presumably right and how do you
do the split with nine home games versus
eight away games right with 17 but I
only heard that last weekend from a
single source I want to be really
careful with it sure but but there's a
lot of those are the two major points
and stumbling blocks but that's the big
story going on right now remember the
NFL owners wanted this wrapped up before
the season yes man that has not happened
well I think part of the reason why is
for many reasons but you know the NFL
100 season is very important to a lot of
people in 345 Park Avenue for sure and
what better way to celebrate the kickoff
of that season than by telling the fans
guess what labor peace for a very very
long time enjoy NFL 100 so perhaps that
might have had something to do with it
but you said something streaming rights
I mean what like how did how did how
does this all play because it's now a
21st century obviously yeah of course if
there is a collective bargaining
agreement or I should say when there is
one right there's optimism there will be
one then that will Roger Goodell and and
and the powers that be at 3:45 Park
Avenue turn there
attention to the broadcast rights and
when I say streaming rights there's all
these new players right including to
zone run by John skipper my former boss
right that are all gonna be in play that
you know the more suitors you have at
the table the higher the price tag will
be or this makes sense and you know the
NFL's already had relationships with
Amazon with Twitter you know testing the
waters Yahoo well I you know I am
mandated to point out the three letters
that's behind me at this desk right here
in AT&T that's right so you know with
with Sunday Ticket etc so how do you see
it all playing out do you see do you see
like a Thursday night or a Sunday night
or a Monday night package literally on
somebody's app so what you see it's
possible there are still there are some
owners and executives that I've talked
to that think that the NFL should be
that ambitious and that pioneering to do
something like that right at the very
least the threat of it is gonna run up
the cost for the network's for NBC CBS
and ESPN which of course now has ABC in
the mix because ESPN wants a Super Bowl
they did ad Lee they do yeah for ABC no
yeah there's been reports about it yeah
that's gonna that's very much something
that's on the wishlist so a Super Bowl
would be it wouldn't be on ESPN on ABC
it would be on ABC oh it would be on ABC
ESPN and you know it will be on the
dodgeball halftime that's right on the
HBO but one quick point you know Jerry
Jones said recently to CNBC yeah he
feels that there will be a 50% premium
in the broadcast deals in part what does
that mean for for the state for a person
well for the layperson is it's 1.9
billion dollars a year that ESPN is
paying the NFL so you do the math it's
three billion dollars roughly or a
little less than that that Jerry Jones
is expecting ESPN in ABC and the Walt
Disney Company to pay that's a huge well
if you do the math then two extra games
it's something that that somebody is
being asked to pay a 50% premium might
be easier to swallow I don't know if
there's likely get more games so you can
certainly see the incentive
roger goodell and the owners in wanting
more regular-season games if they're
going for that much of an increase right
then you could see why it's so important
to them to try to get 18 regular season
games although I don't think it's I
don't think that's up the CBA will ever
go so I'm I'm sitting here saying I
don't want more games in the NFL I'm
pissing off my my boss is at 3:45 you
might be a little bit rich I'd be
careful let me write this down and amend
what about Don Van Natta here on the
Richardson show what role does gambling
sports gambling play in all this a big
one we've talked about it before in fact
two years ago when I sat in this studio
the Supreme Court had not yet done the
landmark decision that they did the
following May that opened the floodgates
right to states across the country right
it has just changed everything it is put
dollar signs in the eyes of all of the
major sports leagues particularly
baseball that we talked about but the
NFL is well I think when Jerry Jones
made that point as to CNBC about the 50%
increased part of it was because of what
he expects the turbocharging of ratings
to occur because legalized games so I
see because again this now dovetails
into a lot cuz you know I've heard that
the amount of money that the NFL could
perhaps reap reap in fright by getting
uh wetting their beak a little but to
use a certain movie phrase pales in
comparison to what a television network
could pay them for one single rights
package and Musburger has been on the
show from his visa and studios saying no
one in Vegas is gonna let let the NFL
take a piece or something like that
without yes about the integrity pretty
much yeah like yeah the integrity fee I
think Musburger like laughed out loud
when I brought up the integrity fee like
I heard him on that yeah he just says
look what integrity it's nonsense
you know that that the integrity fee the
integrity of these of these games right
is run by the bookmakers out there they
do a pretty good job of it and have done
a really good job of it have we had any
betting scandals that anybody knows of
so why do you need to pay it however
there's other ways to do it there's data
that you can possibly sell miners in
some leagues SEC
not the Southeast Conference I'm talking
about like the same type of technology
that's used exactly doc that's right
well for official stats for instance if
you want to writes for official stats in
the NFL the NBA Major League Baseball
then you have to give a tiny piece of
the action to one of the sports leagues
that's being openly discussed huh all
right before I let you go Don banana
here on the rich attitude spending many
many a moon in New York City you know
this as well the the Eli Manning
benching is you know while a jolt for
the Giants it there's it's it's kind of
sad it just feels a little bit saddening
to me I don't know feels to you it does
and you know and to see Daniel Jones
it does feel sad about Eli but even
Daniel Jones he's he's Eli 2.0 right
he's his boring as he lied was a good
thing i dawn when we played do we have
that soundbite Mike do you the the
daniel Jones soundbite from from
Wednesday just play it one more time
here cuz he's on Wednesdays show I had I
had Mike play it for second time because
it sounds so much like Eli this was
Daniel Jones when he met with the media
on Wednesday excited for the opportunity
you never really know when something
like this is is gonna happen and my job
is to be ready and to continue to
improve and you don't know when
something like this can happen I can't
you know can't control that so you know
I understand the responsibility I
understand the the challenge you know I
feel ready and you know certainly
looking forward to opportunity I mean if
that was a transcript he could read
icked ate it by Eli Manning and when I
when I heard Eli at the locker room
yesterday rich talked about being
benched he said it with more enthusiasm
talked about starting I was like sounded
we're excited about you know him being
the backup quarterback of the New York
Giants - Daniel Jones does do you think
it's gonna where I mean I'd Dave Brown
in studio our number one do you think
he's gonna work I I don't think so I
think there's gonna be a long learning
curve look Daniel Jones look great in
pre-season the bottom line is Dave
gentlemen just wants to be right as soon
as possible Daniel Jones in right away
you know gentlemen wants to prove all
those naysayers
remember all the people a lot of pundits
at our network right we're laughing out
loud when Dan Joe Jones got picked with
the sixth overall I mean it was it was
it was ripped observing
I ripped up and down sohave kettlemans
like let's roll the dice I want to be
right now rather than later at dvn jr.
on Twitter at D Van Natta with two T's J
is that for big J journalist is that
what that's although you said that I
appreciate that what a nice compliment
on Instagram
check out the new ESPN docu-series back
story November 3rd is when Sur is when
the Shoeless Joe Jackson / plant ESPN
version on ESPN and check out the
triangle podcast with you as well thanks
for coming on sir great to see Ron Vanna
here on the Rich Eisen show wrap up this
show and more on Fridays show in a
moment for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app